we're two at general features right when
I'm walking you a specific one where
it's just ends and tees and water
country so the end of term we were
recent at before is what are the first
two was where we started which by the
way it can be negative and all that kind
of things and so can the difference the
difference can make your series smaller
plus if it's the end term n minus one
lights off the difference okay
now by the way I know it looks kind of
awkward we're used to writing when
you've got stuff outside brackets you're
used to writing the D at the or whatever
you know coefficient out the front but
we put it at the end and you'll see it
like this in all the textbooks and exams
that fit me because we're trying to get
at how you in save us right it's the
first term plus that make it lots of the
difference it's not the difference lots
of how many ends you hear you get the
idea so if that's the intern what's the
sum of the first n terms which we could
call yesterday right now just to mimic
the process we went through before all
we did was we took the sum of the first
and last terms so I could call that a
plus now in the are your program think
about this what would you call if the
first term was called a what would you
call the last term but textbooks and the
program call it L for last so I'm like
come on why don't you just call ethanol
for first and last but not a plus now
first the last terms where I bet I
haven't run them where else blast them
and then with that son that was the 100
number turned up
you know repair those up right I had to
multiply that by how many pairs I've got
right such as n on - okay now just a
question for you I'm not gonna answer
yes or
good question the series I gave you
before have 50 terms in it so in on soon
became 25 does this work if there's an
odd number of terms hmm like if I only
ask you for the first 40 minutes what
work you have to think about okay now
before I am we resolved that we know
actually what the last term is because
the last term in a series of n terms is
the editor of this guy right so I'm
gonna simplify it a little bit I'm gonna
replace a with one sorry I'm gonna place
L with what it actually is so it should
be okay there's not much I can simplify
upon these set up now by the way it's
actually worth keeping most of you
probably have this line it's it's worth
keeping both of these because depending
on the question that you get sometimes
you get told the difference right you
get to all the common difference other
times you just get told what the first
and last terms are in which case you
don't need to jump to this you can
actually just chuck it straight in there
just like I gave you the first example
okay all right now I'm going to get you
guys to have a bigger map does this work
okay does it work if the series has an
odd number of terms you can try to prove
it
however consuming its inputs to see if
it actually checks out and if it does
where it doesn't or why not